Welcome to Kaiapoi riverbank, behind me we
have the rebuild of the riverbank.
You can see the new Coastguard building - Maritime
Rescue.
The old wharf where the Tuhoe used to sit
has gone, been demolished and replaced with
a rock wall.
As you can see progress is good, it's on schedule
and we're almost in the finished and start
planting stage.
Behind me here, we have our new exciting development
of the south side of the river,
on the main block side.
We have a walkway, we have picnic seating
areas and we have a fishing area with facilities
for cleaning fish for those of you lucky enough
to catch fish in our glorious river.
Development here is in two parts.
On the land side, Jed's exciting new building
comes over towards us from here.
The stop-bank gets modified as part of that
and the slope you are looking at now has steps
built all the way down for sitting in the
sun, looking out over the river.
In the river itself, we are putting 90 metres
of pontoon, which is going to happen this year.
You'll be able to literally drive up in your
fizz-boat, park there, come ashore and have
a latte, just like the Riviera.
Contractors, as you can see, are still there,
but they have finished the major work.
We're up to the finishing touches, the landscaping
and the planting and by next spring it will
all be looking pretty damn good.